flip double salto ou saéeux en tumbling
il faut savoir rebondir objectif de la
discipline effectuer une série de 8
mouvements sur une piste de 25 m de long
à plaisir le 4 septembre le club des
classes sous bois a fait découvrir ce
sport aux spectateurs une mise en
lumière pour cette discipline entre
pirouette et gymnastique c'est vraiment
prendre de la rapidité percuter le plus
haut possible et puis prendre le plus de
plaisir en l'air à faire nos acrobaties
quoi c'est savoir contrôler cette
vitesse pouvoir profiter à fond de sa
vitesse savoir la bloquer aller le plus
haut possible c'est pas du tout connu
malheureusement c'est super
impressionnant à chaque fois que qu'on
fait des démonstrations
ça marche super bien seuls les contacts
avec les pieds et les mains sont
autorisés en compétition les séries sont
notées par des juges qui évaluent
l'athlète selon la difficulté et
l'exécution des figures avec des sauts
pouvant aller jusqu'à 4 m de hauteur le
tumbling défie les lois de la gravité
pour faire du tumbling je pense qu'il
faut il faut avoir une bonne dose on va
dire de dynamisme même si la piste elle
rebondit tous nos athlètes en général ce
sont des enfants qui à la base sont
vraiment très énergiques un minimum de
souplesse et requis quand même on fait
toujours des exercices d'assouplissement
et puis ils font aussi des abdominaux de
la musculation puisque c'est un sport
quand même qui est très physique
plusieurs courses sont organisé au CLA
sous bois allant de l'initiation avec un
cours par semaine à trois cours par
semaine pour les plus expérimentés
actuellement le club de la ville compte
une soixantaine
d'adhérents